you guys ever turned butter before no
yeah back in elementary school yeah me
too really oh yeah you guys did that too
when you go on a field trip and you I
didn't do
it so have you guys ever heard what
about fried rice syndrome fried rice
syndrome what is that what is that you
never heard about fried rice syndome
some [__] woke Asian liberal [__]
is this some Uncle Roger [__] no oh have
you had laan ch fried rice I never had
food really shouldn't go
there [__] phenomenal I've never had
I want to try it [__] but why why
shout outs to C cup CH Li dude shouldn't
go there but that's F they don't want to
shout shout out cup they don't want to
shout out on this video they don't want
to shout out in this video okay okay is
that company so 20 a 20-year-old has
died of fried rice syndrome who you
shouting out again cop I think he's
change the name after eating
leftover after eating leftover pasta
what's that to do with fried rice can
you say one more time after eating
leftover pasta pasta they died you left
it all night fried rice syndrome this
isn't the is this the college student
uhhuh how do you eat pasta and dyet of
fried rice I feel like maybe we did this
before but I'm not did you did this one
I don't know I don't know I'm not sure
if you don't remember the fried rice
syndrome part you didn't I don't
remember that I do remember a college
student eating leftovers that were in a
fridge and then died and I remember we
talked about it here before but I don't
know I don't remember it so it's okay he
is that he is a 20-year-old
student a lot maybe people die from
leading leftovers all the time it's a
syndrome it happens more than once yeah
but name for it happens
why he cooks up some Sketti those left
over short for spaghetti right or or so
initially he cooks up Sketti right uhhuh
short short for spaghetti thank you need
my translator so he puts it in
Tupperware containers right so that that
he could have some left ovies or for
later leftovers thank you thank you so
then after 5 days of the pasta just
sitting out on the counter at room dud
that's why dude that's why temp
temperature he heated some of that up
and then ate it all right so he he puts
that some [__] in the microwave and he
nukes it right son of a [__] thank you
and then that's Matel disease he he
found it to be kind of an odd taste duh
it's got Mo he told one of his friends
it was kind of whack oh wh Haack thank
you and then not good he went out to
play some sports and after 30 minutes he
had to come home due to nausea abdominal
pain a headache he then had diarrhea
vomiting so he starts drinking some
water right and he tries to sleep it off
and the next day he didn't even get out
of his bed for classes his parents
checked in on him and they found him
dead it's called botulism it's called
fried rice syndrome that's what the
article what does that mean the article
from iheart.com says and I'm just
reading it like a good news person they
just
read so that's what I'm here to do I
love.com thank you all I'm going to woke
Asian this [__] the [__] is a fried rice
syndrome they're making cultural blaming
so it's a type of food poisoning called
fried rice syndrome right since rice is
sometimes cooked and left to cool it
room temperature for a few hours and
during that time the bacteria can
contaminate it who the [__] leaves it to
cool
I do well cuz fried rice is made with
leftover rice I eat it right away oh no
no no the rice before you make the fried
rice it's room temp sometimes you can't
even leave something out for like 12
hours not really not on the counter dude
sometimes me and Nikki will make Sky and
then like if we fall asleep cuz we were
[__] or something and then we wake up
in the in the morning and we're like ah
[__] we got to throw it away cuz you can
smell it gy and then sexual intercourse
thank you is there there's only how many
days though 5 days yeah that you can't
blame the [__] fried rice syndrome
that's like 5 days is just like
stupidity but that's what he died of is
fried rice syndrome you have to blame no
he needs to go
onlineold and everyone needs to do this
it only cost $6 and get yourself a food
handler's card what does that mean
because did you know you can't even work
in a food establishment if you don't
have a food handler's card you got to
get SHP safe yeah I get been certified
you got to understand all of the rules
of how to handle food safely you know
cookies last like 5 days not room temp
yeah I get fried rice syndrome dude I
buy cookies from like Albertson and I
could leave it on the counter I open the
lid wherever I want I eat but that's a
bake good dude why you're eating all
that [__] at night you know it dude
you're
eat you trying to get fried rice
syndrome man chicken wings like leftover
chicken wings don't even last in the
fridge for more than 4 days really who
said that makes sense I pushed it to two
weeks me too cook prot cook protein
lasts a little bit longer dude I looked
it up because I always have chicken
wings in there that'll randomly be like
there a week after I go out from a trip
and I come back and it's been like 6
days what kind of sauce is it in though
it's like buffalo sauce lemon pepper
[__] like that buffalo sauce will [__]
you up I think but then it's like 3 to 4
days even refrigerator so how you going
to leave they just don't want to get
sued they just don't want to get sued
how you going to leave pasta on the
[__] room tent you need a nuke it he
didn't nuke it long enough nulear
Warhead sorry I've used soy sauce that's
like six months past to expiration soy
sauces it's okay and it still tastes
good yeah Asian dressing it's it's shelf
stable like you can't get a cup of milk
and leave it out for like a day it
already changed it into gastronomics
whatever it's closer to cheese now it's
closer top milk dude no [__] but it's
still edible right you can cuz you can
make it in mayo I don't know it's like
butter you got to turn it though you got
turn you has to stay certain if it's
like if like let's say your refrigerator
breaks right refrigerator all of the
like the temperature gets to like 65
degrees or whatever you got to throw it
all that throw it out bro you guys ever
turned butter before no yeah back in
elementary school yeah me too really oh
yeah you guys did that too when you go
on a field trip and the do it we went to
Rono Virginia too where like they were
doing all that [__] the am OG's no they
got to do gangsters but they gave us
little ones to do so we're like all
[__] trainning little Butters and at
the end we got to put it on toast and
then we were eating it how you did what
yeah we were [__] Jack it like that D
we were doing it like the real deal in
Roo Virginia with like [__] with big
tits and stuff and then every time they
J like all the guys would just be like I
like JY butter we were just watching
their tits jiggle and stuff that sounds
good I didn't know why I liked it yeah
bosom's bouncing yeah at what age were
you just like man titties are [__]
cool I think I was like five yeah me too
I discovered him young I don't know what
it was about titties but it was just
like man the that's just really good I
was just Advanced and my in my my
parents used to brag they're like like
our kid thinks that titties are really
great second grade very early is that
seven seven seven Mrs Robertson oh it
was your teacher sah for me dude yeah
Mrs Robertson would come in and that
[__] was I didn't know what a low cut V
was but I KN I saw what it was in second
grade dude Miss Sara by the way I think
she wore like kid
pants how the [__] were those titties so
big kid pants I'll never understand and
by the way that was a math class I
should be able to do calculus about it
but I think not even Einstein could
figure it out he could have had the
whole board and he'd be like how the
[__] does she have titties this big and
her waist is this tiny you probably
understand all multiples of two though
oh yeah all pairs yeah I remember when a
teacher would help you with the homework
and she's been like this way and then
she's you could see her cleavage and
then and then the whole time just like
you can't stop looking at it and you're
just a [__] little kid you don't know
why and you're subconsciously with your
pencil just drawing boobs and you're
just like why are boobs so cool so cool
you would take a pen and you would draw
a naked shake you take a pencil you draw
the bikini and then afterwards you were
rais and
go oh that's good I never did that never
did that no I just drew the titties I
knew I was an artist after that that was
the hardest part I probably would have
rubbed my nuts to your homework yeah I
would have humped your homework for
sure I would have cut a hole stick my
dick in it oh that's inventive Glory
that's different way of looking at it
yeah but Anthony's on the other side of
that page are you sure
oh well at least it feels good he sound
like it was a plus that's like the glory
hold Joe's like at least it feels good
cuz Anthony's on the other side of the
gloral he's like at least it feels good
it's a win-win in my books all that
matters is he's also a kid by the way in
this scenario I'm a kid too so I'm not a
pedophile we're the same age good job
Joe he's got you there Ryan what are you
going to say what you do a bottle sick
[__] we're SI we're sick for imagining
both of you yeah you sickos if you're
fantasizing about your childhood
sweetheart and she was underage at the
time are you a pedophile it's a legit
little
bit relax what the you got hot we're
cutting you off no more shots dude you
guys said pedophile and I just got I got
on edge how did we trigger you you're
wet Bart made me wake up at 6:00 a.m.
and I'm slowly falling asleep no I did
he made you huh put a [__] he damned
near put a gun in my head no you told me
to B works hard huh sure you told me to
come we talk I'm just like he told him
to come hard and when bar tells you to
come you got to come no you told me to
come this is one of those videos that
starts derailing kind of slowly and then
picks up [__] momentum really fast
once you realize it's on patreon hey you
I got to say did we were carrying the
load the whole time hey you know what I
like your got loads I like your bit I
like your bit I really
[Music]
did